hi there steve kaufman here
um
you know what i want to talk about today
is multilingualism
uh you know it's suddenly dawned on me
that that multilingualism the idea that
we can speak more than one language
uh it's more than just learning english
or learning french or that idea that
you're in a in a program to learn
another language
it's a state of mind and i think
historically
i haven't done a lot of research but in
the reading that i've been doing
recently about the middle ages
uh when latin was a dominant language or
when students would gather in places
like prague or paris or
italy and they all spoke different
languages
and they all somehow managed to get
along and and of course we know that in
uh
in in germany uh
in the 17th and 18th century before
germany before there was this great
movement of nationalism in germany about
uniting the german speakers into one
country
that latin was a dominant language and
that the court
people at court spoke french as they did
in russia
people spoke the court spoke french
better than russian in many cases
and we know that uh that before the uh
this great move to unify languages in
every country so that there would be one
french language and one chinese language
and so forth that the dialects and
regional uh forms of the language were
very popular so people must have been
able to speak
quite a few languages in order to
communicate
i know this is true in places like
russia and india where there are many
languages and not to mention south
america
so i think we without being an expert on
it i i'm going to take the position
that uh we are
intended to speak many languages and
that that we should almost have like a a
movement or a
cult
of multilingualism
i mean there are people who are into
music there are people who are into
gardening there are people who are into
golf well how about multilingualism
let's see if we get some excitement
around multilingualism
recently i was in france there was a
meetup of of people who were interested
in speaking different languages there
must have been a hundred and some odd
people there there were tables
for you know german russian chinese
japanese spanish italian you name it and
all kinds of people were taking turns
going from table to table
trying out their different languages
boy i'd like to do something like that
here in vancouver or elsewhere
i don't know uh
somehow as i often say people are
conditioned to think of language
learning as something that was done in
school that was very unpleasant
and it's a chore and it's a task and
it's very difficult
and i i don't think it need be but maybe
we can create some excitement around the
idea of multilingualism
i met at the office of
the language commissioner or
commissioner for multilingualism in
brussels on my recent trip
tried to get them interested in link of
course by the way i have a linked
t-shirt on this is the front now let's
see if i can just do this so that you
can see i don't know if this if you can
see it but it says i hope i learned
russian at length
anyway a little bit of
publicity but link is only one of of
many tools that are now available uh on
the web for language learning
multilingualism is much more accessible
today than ever before
uh
when we get to the subject of how we
learn languages and you've heard me rant
before i must say that the the book that
i recently read in germany uh in german
called lehnen
here
uh
by manfred spitzer very interesting book
i commented on the book as well at my
blog
and and the big thing that that came out
of that is that the brain
the brain is very capable it learns all
the time it learns all the time it makes
its own rules it doesn't need to have
things explicitly shoved at it
from observation with the right input
it'll pick things up
and we're constantly learning uh and and
i guess the the point that schmitzer
makes is that often schools
demotivate people so we need to motivate
people we need to be
uh and we need to enjoy our learning
and uh and to be attentive and and
that's what i find too now that i'm
learning several languages and
refreshing my german and so forth i'm
much more attentive when i read i i use
a highlighting pen to highlight certain
structures or certain words because we
can see things and not see them
and so
it's important to focus on if it's uh in
the case of russian it might be the
verbs or it might be cases uh
to focus on certain structures and then
watch for them uh it's in that sense
that correcting errors is helpful
because it makes you more attentive it's
not because
when an error is corrected that you will
then get it right you probably won't
but if you are
prepared to be attentive
and you you recognize that you made a
mistake and then it's explained to you
what what you're supposed to do then you
start watching for it and that i think
helps the brain
to
then
recognize the patterns and create the
rules because ultimately the brain has
to create the rules it's not a matter of
of explaining explicitly
rationally theoretically some rules as
in grammar instruction it's a matter of
helping the brain notice what's
happening in the language
and uh and i think we can do this for a
number of languages and again i should
say that
my theory of language cross training was
confirmed in europe i i
left russian alone and i studied
some italian and german to get ready for
my trip and i was using italian and
german and when i
ran into an unlucky russian on a train
or somewhere i inflicted my russian on
them and i must say i spoke better than
i had spoken before
so multilingualism is anyone out there
interested can we get something going on
this i think there are sites uh
such as this polyglot
site which organizes these meetings but
but let's break down the barriers and
let's not just learn one language let's
learn several is that is that an elitist
concept i don't think so i think there
are people who are not at all elitist
people who are
selling in the bazaars of africa or or
india who who speak 10 languages so that
they can
try to sell their wares to various
foreign tourists whether they be
japanese russian german american or
whatever so multilingualism who's
willing to climb aboard and if you want
an attractive t-shirt like this please
let me know